[Music]
I don't know what's going on tonight a
fake love declaration gets one
contestant sent home as another drops a
bombshell
about his past and I think that I fell
in love with and got married to the
wrong person the drama continues on
Becca kufran season of The Bachelorette
I'm really matter I know the brunette
beauty and her remaining suitors jetted
off to Park City Utah on monday's
episode of the hit ABC show frontrunner
Garrett who received it Becca's a first
impression rose on night one dropped
this shocking piece of information I was
in love once and it was right when I got
out of college I was 23 years old we
both liked adventure and after hanging
out and exploring life together and
going on all these adventures I grew to
love that about her through the point of
getting married to her and one thing led
to another then we got divorced that
revelation came right after Becca
couldn't stop gushing over him
she even compared him to her late father
I feel like my dad has watched him
throughout this and Garrett is just
somebody that he would really really
like
[Music]
and then obviously warms my heart later
in the show Becca ended her group date
early after John Blanc said he was
falling for her and later admitted it
was a lies I just thought that you know
that's that's what you wanted to take
things and you're ready and us you know
that's what you wanted to hear though
Becca's having a tough time on the show
now she revealed to ET last month that
she does get her happy ending